what problems are you running into
dating today you said something about
masculinity and you know certain values
you know can you explain a little bit
more the similar to The Narrative that
you perpet
that okay men like that women are only
ex AKA only visual beings only this and
they only aspire to you at the Finish
Line you achieving full success then
when they're partnering with someone
like me who I know that I'm I have a lot
of contribution and I again I want to be
in my femininity and I will and I start
and my femininity then they have such a
skewed Narrative of what leadership is
in a family and I think that's what
you're running into when you're dating
you're running into the guys yeah
because I'm dating with an intention of
finding my partner just like you say you
look at women and because you're looking
biologically want to find my the person
who's going to give birth to my son my
kids I'm looking the same way I'm
looking at my partner being like all
right you are going to be the father of
my children my passion is my wanting to
have kids right and so therefore I'm
evaluating you yes of course I want you
to have nice teeth or nice whatever like
just for my kids sake right to combat my
genetics maybe but I'm also caring about
your like who you are okay so let me
just set aside the message for a second
you said something about masculinity
what's the problem with masculinity when
you're dating
that they have a skewed idea of what
true masculinity and Leadership is what
is so what's the idea that you're coming
across
um I'm coming across that
perpetuate the blinders close my ears I
am right hear me roar mentality
when I believe that there's a
a strength in a what is there was like a
term it's like
look at us a subservient leader
something that where and I think back to
the most powerful men that I know and
also in history when they're they're
willing to adjust and not just be like
okay hey here's my primary like motives
that I have to look out for but they're
also looking out for their pack their
tribe they're caring about the overall
well-being and the scope of what
masculinity is being defined in social
media is I must close my ears and scream
and only my voice can be heard
um that's interesting
I mean you're basically saying that
every guy that you've come across is
basically a subscriber of my channel and
watches my stuff to the degree that you
define it which is not how I hold it out
to the public no I mean obviously not
your channel but I would more or less
say it's impossible because I reach
almost nobody
the world's a very big place and I don't
reach everybody it would be but and the
the crazy thing is
here
for a reason and my purpose is because I
think it's it's so important for us to
have an open dialogue because in our
core values I don't think you and I are
different in the core but I think we
have to be careful of how we're sharing
the message and I think we're just
minimizing the values and I think one of
the reasons I I can even just tell from
Kelly's Body Language and things like
that she was shutting down a little bit
because of some of the things that you
were saying is that
it's it's important that we recognize
the role of man and woman and I think
sometimes because and as women and
feminists
let me just stop you there for a sec you
said we need to recognize the role of
men and women but then you're also
saying that men are
um
would you say hear me roar yell like
they'll close your ears and just scream
into the wind kind of thing yeah
scream what into the window I'm being
I'm being very hyperbolic right now but
I'm more or less meaning a lot of the
times they believe that the loudest one
in the room is the strongest one in the
room they believe that they and we've
even talked about and touched it in the
beginning of the podcast where we talk
about that you know family day like
you're dating Muslim guys or
um yeah I would say the pro I would say
majority just for my own whatevers they
tend to be Muslim but yeah that's fair
to say that's due to their own
upbringing not because of the content
that they're watching no I uh yes and no
I think there's an influence of because
of their upbringing being being brought
up in a very patriarchal society 100
contributes 100 however I've also been
act different from them though but I
also the interesting thing is is that I
have a baby brother who's a phenomenal
young man and growing into an awesome
human and he is a not a subscriber to
you I don't believe but just in The
Narrative of it all and watching
kind of the choices that he makes and
hearing him and kind of trying to
understand the why behind him he he just
recently got married and some of the
choices that he's making for his
marriage and I'm realizing I'm like but
why aren't you viewing it as a
partnership they lose sight of the
partnership the the beauty of I believe
in a subservient wife and I know that
that sounds really aggressive to women
or feminists because they think
subservient is terrible and disgusting
but I think that's strength and beauty I
find a lot of beauty and submission I
think it's the most gorgeous and
wonderful thing a woman can offer
um and so that being said the
subservient wife isn't supposed to just
sit back and just not like that's not
what a subservient wife is they are
supposed to be the partner they are
supposed to be the aid even if you look
biblical or if you want to go
religiously you don't have to there's a
lot of reference to the female being the
aid helping that the patriarch helping
the head of the household and I think a
lot of the narrative that gets lost when
you're talking about finding a partner
you're losing sight of you need to find
a partner who will be your aide who will
help you be a king and you know in
whatever retrospect that you want to say
it and we could talk about okay so
here's where I'm left completely like
I'm lost I'm just utterly you know
confused because I mean you're saying
that
you want to fall into a feminine role
you want to be led you want to be with a
strong masculine men and then you're
finding guys that you're dating who are
strong masculine men that you don't like
do I no that no I'm you asked me what
Pitfall I'm hitting when I was dating or
when I'm dating the pitfall I'm hitting
is even when I'm having initial
interactions
is that okay maybe they're they're
checking the aesthetic Mark sure that's
not even part of the conversation nor do
I care to have that be but then when I
actually get to have a successful
conversation with them and start to kind
of dig away what their core values are
that's where the unalignment is coming
in so I'm not saying the men I'm
choosing I'm saying when I'm dating
that's okay so where are they missing
choosing men that are that are
historically in our contemporary
that hold those views I mean the types
of minute you're going after
you know in Muslim culture men are the
Patriarchs they're the leaders I mean it
you know yeah but you keep trying to
attribute it to the content that we put
out and I don't see and I also have an
issue with the way it's Being Framed
where when we say that
you know when beauty is very important
and it's the number one attraction
Trigger or it's the most prevalent for
men no one's ever said that it's the
only thing
but when I pose the question of what are
the other values it wasn't answered I
guess that's why I was like I would love
to I would I genuine being so sincere I
would love to understand well I think
like 80. yeah but someone like I think
that you know what you're missing here
is about 80 percent of the attraction
cues for guys are the beauty cues but we
also want her to you know if we're sick
to take care of us
um you know if we're hungry to feed us
you know sort of thing if if we've got a
disorganized home to you know to help us
with it and to organize it right like it
goes beyond the beauty aspect of it but
the thing that but I don't care how good
she can cook if I'm not attracted to her
and I don't want to get into bed with
her she's not going to be my woman right
I don't think anyone disagrees with
level of of you have to have it you have
to be attracted to your partner Point
Blank period and descendants I don't
think anyone could disagree with that
sentence you have to be attracted to you
why are you trying to minimize the
attraction criteria that men have I'm
not I'm minimizing you're saying I'm
attracted to other things I'm
Illuminating that you the narrative is
minimizing the contribution of the
female because they're not as important
as the beauty aspect of it so my thing
is less important
I thought of the term as Beauty object I
agree with you with the beauty part yes
I agree with you I mean that's your
first impression but I don't agree with
the object part and then now you're
saying you don't like the word object
then as well you can take the object you
can substitute it for anything else and
Beauty
I don't even know Q or whatever and it's
like okay why did why did I get that
object
like part like I just well there's men
have it too we're saying well there's a
professor by the name of Dr Warren
Farrell that wrote a book on on the
subject matter and he distilled his
observations down that women view
Madness success objects and Men view
women as Beauty objects that's all that
that is
I guess I was just like I yeah more
specifically he actually said that women
are sex objects not just Beauty objects
I'm just trying to be a little bit more
diplomatic here for YouTube yeah so I
mean I
I agree with you because I know a lot of
immature men but not all men think that
way of course because you have the stats
are there but like maturity has nothing
to do with it though Kelly like that's a
reality of what men are attracted to and
how they make their choices you're right
it doesn't matter what age or how mature
they are but the immature ones are
obviously going to be
the most obvious
um no no no you're taking it back to the
to maturity levels that's that's uh
that's almost insulting you know it it's
it's it's how men like I tell men to pay
very very close attention to what women
react to and what they respond to not
what they've been told to do like for
example
um
a lot of guys will try to resign
themselves to the friend zone to be with
women there's there's there's an entire
Army of men out there that are on Reddit
right now that are like I've been friend
zoned 30 times and I'm such a great guy
and I don't understand why these women
cry on my shoulder and go off and [__]
Mr exciting right
is it though no
it's the guy's fault for for putting
himself in the friend zone because
that's what because hear me out though
that's what that's how women respond to
guys that behave like that they're not
going to prioritize them and they're
certainly not going to prioritize
intimacy with a guy like that who's a
dork I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out